Tình mới rất tổ chương của tổ xe phối hợp với bao gơ điện thực hiện cho thấy khoảng năm
mười thành phố lời nhất thế giới đang trẻ qua tình trạng căng thần viên nước.
Thì lượng nước hay tháng cho sinh hoạt và sân xuất, tiện cật, hoặc vượt quá nguồn cùng sẵn cỏ.
Trong số này, các bạn bị tạm thình vốn năm tại các khu vực lực sé và mức căng thẳng tình
tình như chào mà gồm bắc tình như yói lốt, lốt sinh cho lác, biói đời
general và Delhi.
C căng thẳng viên nước đưa ra định là hệ qua cuộc quan lý tạng viên chưa hiểu qua,
ký thở bởi tất cả những đồng người khẳng só sế của biên đời khí hậu,
một số thành bố khác như lần đơn bằng các và trời cật tàn cũng được sế và nhóm có mức căng thẳng
cào.
Phần tích đầu lập từ giữ liệu vệ tình của đa xa cho thấy sự phân hoa só sế
vì suy hưởng khu hạn và âm bước.
Tại các đô thị trong 2 thập kỳ qua, như thành phố chương à nghe nhận suy hưởng khu hạn
kéo xa, chương khi một số đu thị tại chương phí và đông à có giống hiệu âm ước thông.
Lên nguốc cạnh bảo, thị dưới đứng kiến gần trạng thái phá sản về nước,
khi nhiều nguồn nước suy dạm không thể phục hồi,
bởi sân chương nước ngọt còn cầu đã sạm mạnh trong 2.5 qua,
đông thừa kêu khoảng cơ cưu xa của biển pháp quán lý và điều trình kì thời.